we lie to ourselves we don't tell
ourselves the way things really are and
when we do that then we can't fix our
problems if we can't fix our problems
we're not going to improve so we have to
be truthful to ourselves
you have to stop rationalizing stop
making excuses stop doing yourself
little water down assessments of where
you're really at telling yourself the
truth so that you can get where you
wanna go you should be when you do what
you know you should do when you pay
attention to the little things when you
implement discipline true and
unflinching and unmitigated discipline
in your life when you stop trying to
find a sweat list solution when you look
for weaknesses to work on and all that
starts when you stop lying to yourself
be yourself the truth about where you
are so you can make sure you are getting
the right place and if you're not with
the right place that you can get
yourself on the path to get there the
path of discipline the path of hard work
and the path of
[Music]